merci chers collègues la parole est à
présent à Monsieur Claude Kern sénateur
du groupe Union centriste vous avez 6
minutes chers collègues
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président de la commission des affaires
européennes monsieur le rapporteur
spécial madame la ministre mes chers
collègues nous examinons donc
aujourd'hui l'article 25 du PLF
correspondant à la contribution de la
France au budget de l'Union européenne
cette discussion intervient dans un
contexte particulier
le retour d'une guerre de haute
intensité aux portes de l'Europe une
inflation estimée à 10,9% dans l'Union
européenne des enjeux stratégiques liés
à l’autonomie énergétique très fort
l'année 2023 représente un défi pour le
Niort européenne qui après avoir fait
face à une crise sanitaire sans
précédent et par conséquent à une crise
économique d'ampleur nous sommes
désormais confrontés à la guerre les
conséquences des sanctions imposées par
l'Union européenne à la Russie provoque
sur notre continent une grande tension
en matière d'approvisionnement
énergétique notamment
pour l'année 2023 la contribution
française au budget de l'Union
européenne s'établirait finalement à
24,9 milliards d'euros comme nous
l'apprend l'amenant déposée par le
gouvernement à l'article 25 auquel il
faudra ajouter les droits de douane
évalués à environ 2,2 milliards d'euros
cette contribution est stable par
rapport à celle des années précédentes
nous saluons d'ailleurs l'accord trouvé
entre le Parlement et la Commission le
15 novembre dernier portant le montant
total des engagements à 186,6 milliards
d'euros les fonds supplémentaires
mobilisées pour les programmes visant à
faire face aux conséquences de la guerre
en Ukraine
Erasmus plus l'aide humanitaire ou
encore l'instrument de voisinage de
coopérations développement et
coopération internationale permettront
de faire face à la hausse du coût de la
vie à la crise énergétique et
permettront d'aider les réfugiés
ukrainiens
ce projet de budget reflète également
les grandes orientations des priorités
du Parlement européen pour 2023 à savoir
l'énergie le climat la santé la culture
et les valeurs communes je souhaite
attirer votre attention sur un point de
ce budget qui est la Pâque l'enveloppe
représente 270 milliards d'euros mais
semblent insuffisantes pour faire face à
la multitude de crises auxquelles de
secteur est confronté entre la crise
sanitaire du covid-19 et l'invasion de
l'Ukraine par la Russie le secteur est
en tension permanente depuis plusieurs
années maintenant
si l'on prend une perspective à la long
terme le risque et qu'il devienne
impossible d'assurer la sécurité
alimentaire pour tous le fond de réserve
prévu pour lutter contre les
perturbations du marché ne semble pas à
la hauteur
il est nécessaire que nous agriculteurs
soient dotés d'instruments de gestion de
crise efficace pour l'avenir autre point
important l'utilisation des crédits et
le retard pris dans des dans les
décaissements des crédits européens
notamment ceux accordés dans le cadre de
la politique de cohésion la France se
situe à peine à la moyenne européenne
avec un taux d'absorption des crédits de
66%
pour la période 2014-2020 la France
bénéficiait d'une enveloppe de 27,5
milliards d'euros de crédit au titre des
fédés FSE et ADR FEAMP cette enveloppe
doit être consommée avant la fin 2023 au
30 juin 2022 selon les chiffres de la
NCT les montants restants à programmer
étaient respectivement de 194 millions
d'euros pour le FEDER 20 millions
d'euros pour le FSE IEJ 3,3 milliards
d'euros pour le faitader auquel s'ajoute
47 millions d'euros à engager au titre
du ferme ces chiffres globaux marquent
une forte disparité territoriale les
taux d'exécution étant particulièrement
faibles en outre-mer
le dernier point que je souhaite aborder
la question des ressources propres
envisagez de nouvelles ressources
propres est une nécessité à plusieurs
égards premièrement nous permettre
d'assurer le remboursement du plan de
relance européen ce dernier a été un
instrument décisif de réponse à la crise
économique il a constitué également une
étape importante dans la construction
européenne par la création de capacités
communes d'emprunt première réforme
d'ampleur depuis 1988 du système de
financement de l'Union européenne pour
autant cette avancée ne saurait être
complète sans introduction de nouvelles
ressources propres associées permettant
à compter de 2028 et jusqu'en 2058
remboursement dans la durée de cet
emprunt à hauteur de 15 milliards
d'euros par an
je rappelle que le montant annuel moyen
de la participation de la France ou
prendre au plan de relance serait évalué
à 2,4 milliards d'euros à compter de
2028 si de nouvelles ressources propres
ne sont pas mises en place ces
ressources propres contribueraient
également à financer les objectifs de
transition écologique et le paquet
climat feat for fifty-five présenté en
juillet 2021 enfin elle permettrait
d'éviter un ressaut des contributions
nationales qui contrineraient la
négociation du prochain cadre financier
de 2028 2034 le risque sinon serait de
conduire soit à une réduction de budget
européen susceptibles d'affecter nos
priorités soit un relèvement des
contributions nationales susceptibles de
générer de nouvelles demandes de rabais
dans les deux cas la France risque de
voir les termes de sa participation
financière au budget de l'Union se
dégrader je vous remercie
merci